It's great to welcome to the program today,
Andrew Lakoff, who's a sociologist at the
University of Southern California, also author
of the 2017 book Unprepared Global Health
in a Time of Emergency.
Great to have you, Andrew.
Thanks for having me.
So it's become very in vogue now to point
to, you know, Bill Gates and his TED talk
about at some point we're going to have a
pandemic that we're unprepared for.
And so on and so forth.
And I think for our conversation, I want to
focus in a little more on the nitty gritty
that you've researched and reported on in
some of the specifics.
Maybe to start with, we can talk about this
national stockpile.
What are the origins of the national stockpile?
What types of components are there?
We know, of course, about masks and ventilators
now, but what's the kind of the genesis of
that stockpile?
Well, there are two parts to the story.
The very first idea of a stockpile of essential
supplies to be used in the event of a catastrophic
event took place during the Cold War.
So the Civil Defense Agency built up stockpiles
all around the country of essential medical
supplies.
Now, by the 1970s, those, of course, hadn't
been used.
Fortunately, we never had a nuclear war.
That stockpile was closed down.
But the idea was rekindled in the 1990s in
response to the threat of a bioterrorism attack.
Officials in the Clinton administration were
worried that stockpiles of bio agents like
smallpox and anthrax that had been accumulated
in the Soviet Union had gone missing and might
be in the hands of terrorists.
And they began to think about the need for
stockpiles of biomedical countermeasures in
the event of such an attack.
So that really it got put in place in the
late 1990s and early 2000s.
And what what are examples of specifics that
are part of these stockpiles?
So initially, in response to the threat of
a bioterrorism attack, a lot of the elements
of the stockpile were specifically focused
on possible terror agents.
So there were nerve gas antidotes.
There was millions of vials of smallpox vaccine,
anthrax vaccines.
So a lot of medications in cold storage, eventually
anti-viral medications in preparation for
pandemic influenza.
There also were non-Mitt non-pharmaceutical
supplies, for example, and there have been
a lot of discussion of this ventilators, protective
equipment, that kind of thing when it comes
to the ventilator.
I don't even really want to call it a debate,
but what was for a while fear of a shortage
and what I would characterize as the federal
government's slow implementation of distributing.
I mean, I think that some of those ventilators
could have been distributed far earlier at
very little cost.
If they end up not being necessary, OK, you
send them back.
What else sort of should flesh out our understanding
of the ventilator piece specifically?
I mean, in terms of certainly creating new
ones, we know that the manufacturing process
is not.
You have them in 48 hours.
We're kind of now building up a supply which
will be manufactured over the next three months.
But what what insight do you have into the
entire ventilator situation?
Yeah, the I guess the two step back, one step
back a little bit.
The important thing to keep in mind also is
the process of distribution.
So a lot of planning and thought went into,
you know, once you have supplies available,
how do you decide where they should go?
How do you get them to the right places?
How do you keep track of how many supplies
of a given item you have and where they are
among the various stockpiles in different
parts of the country?
So one piece of the story is, of course, do
you have enough of them?
And that's the question you asked.
But another is, how do you get them to the
places where they're needed?
Yes.
And when it comes to that, is it unrealistic
of me to think that in late January or early
February, there were likely the signals that
would have supported starting to deploy them
to urban areas in some way?
Or is it unrealistic to think that that would
have been an appropriate time to do it, to
be proactive?
Yes.
An important part of stockpile planning is
to put in place the stockpiles of items where
they're needed as soon as you get a signal
that there might be a disaster on the way.
So that's right.
As the World Health Organization was putting
every nation in the world on alert in late
January, as officials were beginning to counsel
the administration that there might be an
epidemic of a very dangerous disease on the
way.
In particular, a respiratory disease.
Indeed, that would have been the time to start
figuring out whether we had enough ventilators
and whether they were in the right place.
So one more thing on the stockpile thing,
and then I want to move on to to a few other
things.
Jared Kushner had this very strange Orwellian
moment where he said the stockpile is.
Our stockpile.
It's not the state stockpile.
I didn't.
I don't even know what to make of that in
the sense that while everybody I guess unless
you're in Guam or Puerto Rico, you're in one
of the states like we are the states.
But is there anything about the stockpiles
origin that makes that statement less Orwellian?
Well, it's a very confused statement.
It doesn't understand the whole premise of
how governmental preparedness has to work
in a federal system like the United States.
The whole presumption of a system that is
run by the federal government is that states
would make requests to the federal government
for the items when they need them and that
there would be a elaborate and sophisticated
coordination between the federal government
and the states.
So it's not a competition between the federal
government and the states.
It's not that it's belongs to the federal
government or us.
Whatever Jared Kushner meant by us, but rather
the real effort is to figure out what the
states need and how can we get that material
to them yet.
Elaborate and sophisticated is not matching
up in my mind with a lot of a lot of what
we've seen.
So let's.
What are some other ways in which as a planet
we are sort of underprepared for this type
of hundred year pandemic that we're experiencing
now?
I mean, we know we don't have a vaccine, but
that's a process.
You need to sequence the virus and then there's
a process to go through.
Most optimistically, there'd be no emergency
use vaccines available in the fall for health
care workers.
And then we're looking at 20 21.
We talked about the ventilator distribution
component, although fortunately the actual
shortage in the US has been has been minimal.
What are some other ways that we're fundamentally
underprepared for dealing with something like
this?
Well, I think what we've seen in the last
couple of months is that you could have pretty
elaborate and sophisticated preparedness plans
in place.
And in fact, under the Obama administration,
very detailed playbooks were put together
for each step of coordinated response to a
potential dangerous epidemic or pandemic.
Yes.
But if you don't if you have those in place,
but you don't know you've got the plans or
you're not you're not aware of the plans,
you haven't practiced them or you even don't
take them seriously.
Then when the actual event happens, you're
not going to you're not going to respond adequately.
But are there some other bottlenecks that
are very specific in terms of.
I mean, you know, international travel is
very different now than it was during the
1918 flu pandemic.
And the speed with which pathogens can be
moved around is a part of it.
Which systems are simply not prepared to really
deal with this at the start?
Yeah.
I mean, I think that at that it's really a
variegated story around the world.
I think you can you can look at countries
like South Korea or Germany and see that although
of course, there's not yet a vaccine and there's
not even an effective medication.
There are non-pharmaceutical interventions,
especially combined with widespread diagnostic
testing, that can do a decent job of mitigating
the disease threat.
Obviously, they can't cure it.
But so so in certain countries that really
have thought carefully about how to do this
and have strong health systems in place where
it looks not so catastrophic in other parts
of the world where you don't have competent
government, government leadership, you don't
have a really strong health system, you have
a lot of economic inequalities.
That's where we see the catastrophic event
unfolding.
One of the things I've been pointing out is
that the virus has exposed the underlying
fragility of a lot of the systems that sometimes
feel very, very solid.
And, you know, we could find two or three
months ago, we could have found a number of
indicators of the American economy that weren't
great.
Right.
I mean, huge inequality and wages have been
stagnant, etc.
But by the traditional measures, the economy
was humming along quite well, high consumer
confidence, low unemployment, high stock market,
etc.
The fragility that is exposed by a complete
hundred and eighty degree turnaround in just
a few weeks for me has been one of the most
stunning things.
And I don't know that, you know, the system
we have doesn't reward being proactive.
It's not that profitable to be proactive,
but that's been a huge thing for me.
Yeah, no, I completely agree.
Not only is the health systems for fragile.
The supply chain system is fragile.
The security of what we call essential workers
is precarious.
One thing that preparedness planners didn't
think a lot about was the how to deal with
the economic after effects of these non-pharmaceutical
interventions like social distancing measures.
So I think countries that have a much more
resilient economic system in place have turned
out to be much better prepared than countries
like ours that really focused on efficiencies
at the expense of resilience.
That's interesting.
We know from a medical perspective with certain
countries were far better prepared.
South Korea certainly comes to mind, but which
are the countries that economically were much
better prepared?
Well, I think I would say the countries in
which it was taken for granted that you would
you would actually provide stable income.
So you look at some of the Western European
countries that have, instead of furloughing
workers or laying off workers, have kept workers
pretty much on the job and employed through
government payments.
I think you need a you need a an assumption
of a social welfare system to pass that kind
of legislation in an emergency context, which
is something we, of course, don't have here.
Are there other countries?
What other countries are at the top of the
list in terms of dealing with the medical
part?
I mean, what's happened in South Korea is
incredible.
They still don't have 300 deaths.
Deaths.
They don't.
They're under 300 deaths, which is just stunning
given that their first case was officially
found within hours of the first U.S. case.
Germany has done well, although they had a
far larger outbreak.
And I think it was just a little more advanced
by the time they got around to it.
There is a lot of debate about what's happening
in Sweden, certainly a higher death rate now,
but you're sort of taking a bet that maybe
the subsequent waves won't be as deadly because
you'll have higher immunity.
We just don't know.
My my view is that we just won't know that
for a while.
What are the other countries that medically
have done the best?
Yeah.
And one thing I would I agree with you about
the uncertainty about the outcome in a place
like Sweden.
But one thing I would say is that insofar
as a claim is being made that we're kind of
accidentally following the Swedish model in
Sweden, they have made sure that the health
systems are strong and that people, you know,
will have available medical care.
So it's one thing to let things go without
a plan in place.
It's another thing to to sort of carefully
keep things less shut down and elsewhere when
you know that you're gonna be able to provide
serious medical care for those who do get
sick.
I think the other countries to look at very
carefully, although, of course, there are
different situations in the United States
are East Asian countries.
So Taiwan, Singapore, places that experienced
stars were very proactive early on and in
January, putting in place testing systems,
contact tracing systems, isolation practices,
in some cases closing down schools and businesses
early and in other cases in other cases not.
But it looks like those countries have, for
the most part, weathered this much better
than the United States has.
One of the ideas that's floated about when
we look at some of these other countries is
that we can't really do what some of those
countries do because they are far more authoritarian
now with the case of South Korea.
South Korea ranks higher than the United States
on the democracy index, only slightly so.
But but they do.
And certainly to say that South Korea handled
that because they're an authoritarian system
of government seems completely false when
it comes to some other places.
Is there anything to the idea that not all
of these measures would be tolerable in the
United States politically?
Well, I think, you know, again, just to add
to your point, a place like Germany, there's
no way you could make an argument that contemporary
Germany is more authoritarian than the United
States.
But it really has to do with competency, trust
and expertise, proactive government intervention
and trust by the public in that intervention.
So it's not so much a question of authoritarian
versus democratic, but when you have a when
you have a liberal democratic country, what
kind of system do you need to have in place?
Which, of course, we had we had planned for
such a system here that wouldn't invade fundamental
rights.
The problem is we didn't implement that plan.
Last thing I want to touch on going forward.
There may be a second and third wave.
There may just be a second one.
This first wave may never really diminish.
And it may sort of go into the time where
we would potentially have a second wave.
We don't know the timeline for a wide, widely
available vaccine.
We don't exactly know when any of the 70 or
80 possible treatments may turn up to work
very effectively.
There's economic concerns.
We still aren't testing enough.
What are you looking at and what would be
the lowest hanging fruit to do over the next
six months?
Well, I think what we what we're obviously
going to have a period of trial and error
over the next six months as we figure out
what works and what doesn't work, because
obviously we won't have a vaccine in that
period or very it's very unlikely we would.
I think what we need what I'm looking at is
just the extent to which we're not flying
blind as we go forward.
How much are we actually tracking what's going
on and proactively intervening before things
get bad again?
Each time we try to lessen our social distancing
measures.
So the more information we have, the better.
And the more that information ties into actual
rapid policy decisions, the better outcome
we'll have or over the next few months.
So it sounds like at an absolute minimum,
no matter what the trajectory is going to
be, if we don't have dramatically more testing,
we are going to be short on the information
we need to really make informed decisions.
I think that's right.
We need more.
We need a dramatically more testing, but we
also need to new to, you know, what we're
gonna do with the results of those tests.
We actually need a plan that links tests to
policies.
So it's not just the testing, but also acceptance
of guidelines from from a central coordinated
government effort that will lead to less bad
outcomes.
We've been speaking with Andrew Lakoff, sociologist
at the University of Southern California,
also author of the book Unprepared Global
Health in a Time of Emergency.
Andrew, I really appreciate your time today.
Thanks for having me here.